was macht diesen fall und diesen prozess
in seiner dimension und seiner
grausamkeit so einzigartig ja das war
bei diesem fall sagen muss es gab ja
schon die felle in lichte und auch in
bergisch gladbach war eben der dritte
große fall und plötzlich bekam man das
gefühl das ist ein problem
mitten in der gesellschaft immer wieder
werden diese pädophilen ring ausgehoben
diese kinderschänder die sich im
internet vernetzen und hier in münster
war eben die dimension das ausmaß der
daten es war wie gesagt mittlerweile ist
man fast 1000 terabyte und das muss man
sich vorstellen und der haupttäter
adrian v hatte einen richtig großen
server raum eingerichtet in dem er hoch
professionell die ganzen daten
gespeichert hat und neben dem auch im
internet verkauft hat er hat auf der
einen seite mit diesen daten sich neue
kinderpornografie beschafft er hat zum
anderen aber auch diese
kinderpornografie verkauft hat damit
sehr viel geld gemacht und der
serverraum war auch im keller seiner
mutter er mir eben schon gehört sie ist
mit angeklagt auch da sage ich gleich
noch mal was zu das macht das auch noch
mal so perfide und schrecklich und
dieser server haben wir so gesichert
dass denn die polizei einfach
eingedrungen wären hätte die tür
aufgebrochen hätten sich alle daten
gelöscht
deswegen hat die polizei mehrere tage
vorsichtig versucht in den raum zu
kommen um die daten nicht zu zerstören
auch das ist eine dimension an
organisierte kriminalität die kannte man
bisher so nicht von pädophilen und zu
der mutter noch mal zu sagen vom
haupttäter spricht die stiefel eines
opfers sie hat die taten nicht nur
gedeckt sie hat regelrecht beihilfe
geleistet sie hat die laube zur
verfügung gestellt sie hat gewusst was
dort passiert wir haben es eben beitrag
gehört sie hat sogar per sms viel spaß
gewünscht
sie ist morgens gekommen und hat den
männern nach den schrecklichen taten bei
dieser geburtstagsfeier so wie sie es
nannten und muss ich das wirklich
vorstellen sie schenken sich eine
vergewaltigung sorry mit kleinen jungen
zum geburtstag und missbrauchen diese
jung wie es in der anklage heißt
wechselseitig überstunden und dann kommt
morgens diese oma in dieser glaube macht
den männern frühstück die halbnackt am
tisch sitzen und sich gegenseitig
erzählen was sie denn da tolles in der
nacht alles gemacht haben das ist
einfach unfassbar
man muss auch noch sagen zu dieser
besonderen nacht dass es so der der der
schreckliche höhepunkt dieser grausam
missbrauchs taten hat der vater der auch
seinen sohn zu missbrauch mitgebracht
hat tobias es hat dann noch zu den
anderen männern gesagt als er seinen
kleinen jungen in die mitte des 3
führte zu den anderen männern das buffet
eröffnet dass es an grausamkeit und an
schrecklichkeit überhaupt nicht zu
überbieten sie haben die jungen
betrachtet wie die gegenstände ist die
ihn nutzen für ihre perversen fantasien
und das einzig gute an dem fall ist eben
dass alle beweismittel natürlich da sind
weil alle diese missbrauchs tagen sind
alle auf video gesichert sie sind
teilweise auf diesen servern gefunden
worden auf mobiltelefon und was auch
noch eine besondere dimension war aber
jan v der haupttäter ist mit seinem
stiefsohn quer durch deutschland
gefahren einmal mit einem mercedes vito
später auch noch mit einem vw bulli und
hat diesen jungen anderen pädophilen
ihrem netz kennengelernt hat zum
missbrauch angeboten wir haben diesen
jungen dann in dem auto missbraucht und
der stiefvater hat dann auch noch den
corona lockdown im frühjahr dafür
benutzt um dann mit dem jungen der
schule frei hat es war ja keine schule
quer durch die republik zu fahren über
wochen und in überall fremden männern
eben zum missbrauch zur verfügung zu
stellen und das ist eine dimension die
hat man bisher so nicht gekannt und man
kann nur hoffen dass gerade der
haupttäter auch sicherungsverwahrung
bekommt in diesen verfahren hier denn
das ist auch noch ein punkt er war
vorbestraft er hatte schon zwei mal zwei
jahre auf bewährung bekommen weil
angeblich reumütig war eine therapie
machte und das jugendamt keine gefahr
als er die alleinerziehende mutter
kennenlernte mit dem jungen und sagt nee
da besteht keine gefahr der ist ja
therapiert er ist reumütig der kann mit
der frau und dem kind zusammenleben dass
das ein fataler irrtum war für die
gerade insbesondere natürlich für den
jungen zeigt sich jetzt mit diesen
vorwürfen in der anklageschrift noch
einen satz vielleicht zum verfahren
heute
es ist davon auszugehen dass die
öffentlichkeit sehr früh ausgeschlossen
wird zum schutz der opfer weil die
grausamen details in der anklage die uns
vorliegt einfach nicht genannt werden
sollen in der öffentlichkeit auch nicht
gelernt werden können ich habe leider
teile der anklage selber gelesen und
kann nur sagen das kann man wirklich
kaum einen menschen zumuten welche
grausamkeiten den kindern da widerfahren
sind
mehr nachrichten